what a night for White Lotus and Ted
lasso but a magical night for this
Hollywood Legend the one and only Cheryl
Lee Ralph welcome to Entertainment
Tonight she really was the belle of the
ball E.T with Cheryl after her emotional
Emmy win fit for a Hollywood dream girl
hold that up again one more time and the
Emmy goes he goes too Cheryl Lee
when I heard them say my name I didn't
believe it and then you've let out this
beautiful song
I am an endangered species
[Music]
but I sing no
no
victim's song
to anyone who has ever ever had a dream
and thought your dream wasn't wouldn't
couldn't come true I am here to tell you
that this is what believing looks like
[Applause]
Cheryl's son shared two moments this
angle watching his mom win from the
audience and praying backstage before
the ceremony Cheryl who plays a
kindergarten teacher on Abbott
Elementary is only the second black
woman to win supporting actress in a
comedy series since Jack a Harry 35
years ago jacket tweeted welcome to the
club I wonder if I get paid my money for
this
congratulations to you could Dare I ask
you to sing and not know where my voice
belongs
Quinter Brunson Elementary Cheryl's
co-star and boss Quinta Brunson got a
standing ovation after her win for
writing the show's pilot and then Jimmy
wake up I won
presenter Jimmy Kimmel continued his
comedy bit pretending to be passed out
right into Quinta's acceptance speech
Kimmel received tons of backlash online
I don't know tomorrow maybe I'll be mad
at him I'm gonna be on the show on
Wednesday so I might punch him in the
face Jimmy you're alive I know I'm alive
right I'm okay and celebrating Quincy
tonight I mean is it not an amazing
night to witness you know what she is so
unbelievably talented and she's a lovely
person as well
and fun fact they took all their Emmy
marketing money and used it to buy
supplies for public school teachers
that's what it's all about our show
doing it it just backs up what the show
was about if I could get you all my
money I would and another amazing Abbott
moment Tyler James Williams and Henry
Winkler both up for outstanding
supporting actor in a comedy series on
our platform let me just say what a
wonderful soothing teacher he played
he I wish I had a teacher like that in
my life it's filmed me man that's that's
beautiful thank you those two went head
to head but the Emmy went to Ted
lassell's Brett Goldstein for the second
year in a row well I have realized this
my Mom stole the first one I have to
keep this one away from my dad otherwise
I'm never gonna have it that way how's
the season going you're shooting it
right now in London we're pretty close
to the end is this the end oh boy this
question we've been writing it like it's
the end but I know we would all love to
do it forever it's all in Jason's hands
you have to ask Jason that will there be
a season four of Ted lasso I don't know
it's up to more factors than myself I I
apologize for not giving you um a more
direct answer because I understand that
that's helpful for headlines
her lead actor in the comedy series
the Emmy for the outstanding comedy
series goes to Ted lasso yeah and there
were actually four big wins for the Ted
lasso team Jason thanked his kids with
ex Olivia Wilde Otis Daisy I love you
very much uh and uh
three at some point
caught up with the cast celebrating at
the Apple TV plus party which cast
member is going to get the rowdiest
tonight do you think I will drink
everyone under the table but I won't get
Rowdy because I'm a gentleman I took a
picture of Brad when he won last year
and so we've recreated that photo
already and I've put them both together
already and put it on Twitter
can we talk about this bro moment on the
red carpet it happens yeah
it's happening right now he's lost come
back to me Phil sorry where am I the
dreamy guy
oh and can we get back to Henry Winkler
for a moment check out his other
heartwarming run-in with the White Lotus
star Connie Britton I mean honestly
you've been an inspiration to me for my
whole life
cry meeting you maybe we'll work
together
Connie B from your mouth
Connie who was up for outstanding
supporting actress in a limited series
Lost to co-star Jennifer Coolidge thank
you to my amazing team
this marks the 61 year old's first Emmy
win and the big moment went viral after
she embraced the playoff music wait hold
on okay
backstage Jennifer kicked off the
celebrations posing with her new
accessory
the HBO show cleaned house it not only
took home outstanding limited series but
Murray Bartlett won the golden statuette
for supporting actor Creator writer and
director Mike White also won
back-to-back Awards impressive for the
former Survivor contestant who finished
second in 2018. I love writing I love
doing what I do like don't come for me
don't vote me off the island in please
it was actually Mindy Kaling and BJ
Novak who presented Mike the honor the
former office co-stars and besties kept
us guessing about their relationship
with this that show
that would take up your whole life you
had no choice but to form insanely
complicated relationships with your
co-star that's right and did we miss a
Tom Holland shout out from the Emmy's
youngest two-time winner Zendaya thank
you to my friends and family some of
which are here tonight
um was that nut no no
no he's part of my loved ones so where
was her loved one Tom was in New York
shooting his 1970s Anthology series The
crowded room but just 12 days ago they
celebrated her 26th birthday together
what did we do for 26. 26 I just I was
just chilling yeah I was chilling with
loved ones
what you gonna do tonight I'm gonna do a
little wardrobe change you know I'm
gonna do what you know two little
two-step and then head on home
Zendaya did just that quick changing to
Red Valentino for the HBO bash while a
man decipher it took her award to bed
after some party yeah I'm like it's uh
surreal and I'm super sober Amanda got
support from adoring hubby Thomas
sadoski who skipped his own movie
premiered to be there it's the best day
night ever no I know mostly because the
kids aren't here no no I don't mean that
we love our kids
[Music]
Kaley Cuoco made her PDA filled red
carpet debut with her new man Ozarks Tom
Pelfrey Sarah Paulson and girlfriend
Holland Taylor got cozy while Melanie
lynskey's hubby Jason Ritter played
stylist
I don't know how it got so strange in
memoriam performer John Legend and
expectant wife Chrissy Teigen showed off
the Emmy snack box her caption oh I'm
gonna need more than this LOL where's
the baby what's in here
also hitting the carpet Ben Stiller his
date wasn't his recently reconciled wife
Christine Taylor instead he brought
their look-alike 20 year old daughter
Ella The Marvelous Mrs maisel Rachel
brosnahan's constant plus one husband of
six years Jason Ralph we have two
episodes left to shoot how's that
getting shooting these last two episodes
it's got to be heartbreaking I think
it's finally starting to hit us I grew
up on this show and uh I'm pretty sure
I'm in for a delayed quarter life crisis
one more time well this TV twosome will
never be done
and the nominees
it's one of those forever jobs isn't it
the crew everything you stay away from
this oh this
Julia Garner also made it a date night
with her rocker husband Foster the
People's hunt Man Mark Foster just take
me out it's Julia Garner
backstage the double nominee planted a
kiss on her third Ozark Emmy for
supporting actress in a drama series
Julia admitted she blanked on thanking
man okay wow uh did not um I blacked out
my husband I forgot to thank it's an out
of Body Experience Jean Smart
most unexpected acceptance speech shout
out came from lead actors in a comedy
winner Gene Smart I lost a bet I
promised her man thank you for the botox
thank you I'm serious
the hacks TV Legend also thanked co-star
Hannah Ein binder who teased how the two
will reconcile in season three I think
that they're able to just come together
and really just Thrive go ahead admire
your work dope six Michael Keaton told
me winning's cool and all but this was
his next level moment Michael Keaton
and how about that Opera handsome anyway
seriously how many has she won Oprah has
15 Emmy Awards but all it took was two
for squid game to make history
lead actor in a drama winner Lee
jong-jae and outstanding director for a
drama series huangdong yoke are now the
first Asian and Native Koreans to win
those categories so where are you going
tonight we'll drink right
that's the universal language succession
succession beat out both squid game and
Better Call Saul in the outstanding
drama category but Bob Odenkirk told me
he will always feel like a winner after
surviving his onset heart attack last
year listen the reason I'm here is
because my castmates were standing right
there and Ray ran over and grabbed my
head and yelling to get someone this is
why this works I go too far and you pull
me back our friendship saved us because
we were allowed to go back to our
trailers but instead he hung out and we
we saw him start to faint I dubbed to
catch his head before he hit the
concrete if he had been in his trailer
be a very different story
foreign